Estados Unidos ha difundido el vídeo que
demuestra que en efecto una caza ruso
fue el que hizo que el dron
norteamericano que patrullaba la zona
del mar Negro el pasado martes se
precipitase contra el agua en aguas
internacionales las imágenes difundidas
que tiene una duración de 33 segundos
muestran primero un avión acercándose
por la parte trasera del dron y
rociándolo con combustible tal y como
había dicho Estados Unidos en un primer
momento después se ve al mismo avión o
otro del mismo modelo un sujoy 27
acercándose todavía más y golpeando al
parecer al dron en la parte posterior
que en sus últimas imágenes muestran la
hélice parcialmente destruida los
operadores del dron destruyeron mientras
caía toda la información todo el
software toda la información que había
recopilado para que no cayese en manos
enemigas pero
Moscú que desde el principio ha dicho
que el dron se precipitó contra el agua
por una maniobra brusca ha dicho que no
renuncia a obtener el fuselaje del
aparato y tratar de obtener algunos de
los secretos que